mes chers amis je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier chacune et chacun d'entre vous
cadrez lui dans chacune de nos
fédérations pour la part que vous avez
prises à la préparation de ces
investitures et je voudrais surtout
remercier notre président nicolas
sarkozy qui ont remettant en ordre de
marche notre formation politique nous
permet tout comme au départemental du
mois de mars dernier d'aborder dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
à cinq semaines de la première du
premier tour des élections régionales
cette échéance dans les meilleures
conditions
merci monsieur le président sarkozy je
voudrais remercier tous ceux des membres
de la commission nationale d'investiture
qui ont participé à plus de 40 heures de
débat pour leur assiduité pour le
travail qu'ils ont fait dès coûte de
dialogue et je voudrais remercier tous
les cadres les élus de chacune de nos
fédérations qui sont venus nous faire
part de leurs sentiments
je demande simplement à ce que là où la
ceni s'est prononcée parce que là où
vous allez vous prononcer tout à l'heure
sur la base des choix que vous ferez ce
soin le respect de ce choix qui soit
fait et qui traduisent votre volonté par
le vote que vous émettrez qu'ils soient
respectées dans chacune de nos
fédérations et dans chacun des chats
dans chacune de nos régions
mais avant avant cela je voudrais vous
dire un petit mot de la manière dont
nous abordons cette ce dernier mois
voyez vous nous nous trouvons frappé
aujourd'hui par la double peine la
double peine de hollande à paris et dans
la plupart de nos régions
même si elles sont recomposées en
passant de 22 à 13
d'une gouvernance socialiste qui pendant
18 ans pour certaines ont apporté à une
situation économique absolument
catastrophique pour faire référence à la
région provence alpes côte d'azur
je voudrais vous dire que d'avoir
augmenter la fiscalité de plus de 25%
pour un budget annuel de 2 milliards 200
millions d'euros avoir une dette de 2
milliards 600 millions d'euros avoir mis
sur le bord du chemin près de 138
l'emploi sur les quatre dernières années
démontre là peu de pertinence des
politiques à la fois national et
régional il ya au delà de cela une
opacité dans les subventions qui sont
distribués et tout cela dans un cadre
national où nous voyons combien le
laxisme notamment de la politique menée
par madame taubira n'est pas sans
conséquence dans des domaines de
compétence de la région
je pense aux transports ferroviaires et
je pense au lycée en matière de sécurité
notamment
c'est aussi une politique en échec sur
l'ensemble des dispositifs de vie
quotidienne et de soutien à l'activité
économique
car dans nos régions comme au niveau
national les socialistes préfèrent faire
de l'idéologie
plutôt que de s'attaquer sérieusement au
problème
eh bien lorsque nous voyons ce qui s'est
passé dans notre pays ces 10 derniers
jours je n'avais jamais vu cela de ma
vie politique
un ministre du budget qui soit capable
de dire si vous voulez ne pas payer la
feuille d'impôts que vous avez reçus
vous pouvez un ministre du travail
auquel on pose la question savez vous
combien de fois on peut renouveler un
cdd qui est incapable d'y répondre
un cadre d'air france
et molesté par des syndicats sans que
l'autorité de l'état de sa firme et des
gens du voyage qui agissent comme vous
le savez sur des territoires de france
sans que là aussi l'autorité de l'état
ne soit au rendez vous c'est une
véritable caricature que du gouvernement
qui en même temps se traduit dans
l'image auprès de nos électeurs dans
chacune de nos régions
alors tout simplement une impréparation
jamais vu qui montre dans toute son
étendue l'urgence de l'alternance et
cette alternance doivent d'abord passer
par notre victoire aux régionales
la baisse de la fiscalité tout orientée
vers l'emploi et l'innovation renforcer
la sécurité dans les lycées et dans les
trains que nous voulons voir plus
l'ombre eux que nous voulons voir
ponctuelle ou nous ne voulons plus de
ces jours de grève où nous voulons plus
de cette délinquance qui vient frapper
chacun de nos usagers notre cadre de vie
et notre environnement et maud fontenoy
qui est en retard ce matin à cause d'un
avion qui est en difficulté au départ de
toulon nous rejoindra dans la journée
mais jouera auprès de nicolas sarkozy un
rôle fondamental tout comme je suis fier
de l'avoir à mes côtés dans le combat
pour l'environnement et l'écologie au
service de l'économie dans la région
provence alpes côte d'azur alors les 6
et 13 décembre prochains
il s'agira aussi pour nos concitoyens
d'émettre un double vote sanction c'est
la possibilité pour eux de dire non à la
politique des majorités sortantes et de
dire non à la politique du gouvernement
de hollande et de valse c'est la
possibilité enfin d'émettre un vote
d'avenir et un vote de modernité car
décidé de changer l'orientation de nos
régions
c'est une manière démocratique et
moderne de changer la france
car oui mes amis le temps est révolu où
tout peut venir d'en haut du
gouvernement central si nous voulons
réussir l'alternance et le changement il
faut le faire à tous les échelons de
notre pays et la région est un échelon
est essentielle
mais si dans leur région nous combattons
le bilan calamiteux des majorités
socialistes
tout montre aussi que notre adversaire
le plus résolu dans sa complicité avec
le parti socialiste
je le dis c'est le front national il
faut mobiliser les électeurs
tous les électeurs ils n'appartiennent à
personne et leur montrer tous les
dangers du vote en faveur des candidats
lepénistes
ce sont les candidats du slogan ce sont
les candidats du y en a marre c'est
tellement facile
y en a marre de l'insécurité le faisons
nous pas suffisamment preuve d'autorité
lorsque nous gouvernons d'ailleurs
lorsque nous gouvernons le front
national défend et lorsque la gauche ou
vers le front national monte
et bien il y en a marre contre
l'insécurité et y'en a marre facile et
migration et il y en a marre face à la
fiscalité
et il y en a marre face au cancer
il y en a marre face alzheimer y en a
marre face à parkinson
y en a marre face à la canicule au mois
de juillet et face aux grands froids au
mois de décembre
ah ben oui on va voter y en a marre eh
bien ce n'est pas la solution
les solutions elles viennent de ce que
nous proposons ici et nulle part
ailleurs
avec nos amis du centre dans chacune de
nos régions
il ne propose aucune alternative
politique à l'arrivée ce soir l
isolement
la fuite des investisseurs et au final
le d'éclat pour chacun de nos
territoires
je vous le dis clairement parce que j'en
suis convaincu les apprentis sorciers
que sont le parti socialiste depuis les
années considère que le front national
et leur assurance vie mais le piège
pourrait se retourner sur eux et c'est
désormais le parti socialiste qui
pourrait devenir l'assurance vie du
front national eh bien nous ne voulons
pas de cela parce qu'en réalité le rêve
de monsieur cambadélis et le rêve de
monsieur hollande c'est de pouvoir
camoufler la défaite qui les attend par
un succès du front national
ce dont il rêve c'est que le soir du
second tour on ne parle pas des régions
perdues par le parti socialiste
ni de celle conquise par l'opposition
républicaine mais que tout se focalise
autour d'une victoire qu'ils voudraient
rendre possible dans le pen au nord ou
d'un le pen au sud ce serait pour le
parti socialiste
une parfaite opération d'enfumage c'est
pourquoi les apparatchiks socialistes
sont à la manoeuvre dans la grande
tradition du sectarisme triomphant il
dresse un infâme signe d'égalité entre
nous et le front national
ils cherchent à nous assimiler au front
national pour nous perdre
eh bien voyez-vous je crois que nous
n'avons aucune valeur en partage qu'elle
soit morale ou qu'elle soit sur notre
vision de la stratégie économique et de
la cohésion sociale de notre pays
je me sens plus social que les
socialistes
je me sens plus écologiste que les verts
ce sont les politiques que nous
conduisons qui aujourd'hui peuvent
redonner de l'espérance aux français et
jeudi à monsieur hollande qu'il me
semble bien peu préoccupé à neutraliser
les 5000 personnes fichées s sûreté
nationale dans notre pays dont nous
avons découvert l'existence par la
révélation du ministère de l'intérieur
lorsqu'il a fallu que deux militaires
américains neutralise un dangereux
terroriste dans le thalys il y a deux
mois de cela
oui il me semble moins préoccupé par
cela que part dénoncé le fait que le
front national veille assimilée ici les
musulmans avec les islamistes
nous ne faisons pas la confusion nous
voulons combattre le radicalisme
c'est une chose est de l'autre côté nous
voulons que les valeurs de la république
quelle que soit sa religion quelle que
soit sa condition sociale
quelle que soit sa couleur de peau
quelle que soit son origine culturelle
elle se retrouve derrière toutes celles
et tous ceux qui dans leur immense
majorité dans notre pays ne se
reconnaissent que derrière les lois de
la république est bien partout
nous relèverons le défi
nous dirons et répéteront que nous
n'avons qu'une valeur avec ces
extrémistes que tous nous c'est pas la
morale comme l'efficacité politique
l'humanisme comme l'esprit de liberté
permettez moi d'ajouter une autre raison
de combattre le front national a baissé
nos régions cette apc le b le pays
confié à la famille le pen ou autres
dirigeants du front national le destin
d'une région s'est fracturé notre pays
c'est pour cela je le dis en pesant mes
mots combattre le front national battre
le front national c'est un devoir
national
c'est notre responsabilité devant la
nation devant la nation c'est notre
responsabilité de défendre la république
ses idéaux et ses valeurs et ses ce
qu'ensemble nous allons faire avec une
immense majorité de français qui
refusent la catastrophe sans fin du
pouvoir socialiste et la folie sans
limites de la politique du front
national
mes chers amis je suis convaincu qu'avec
nous vous nourrir est toute cette
espérance pendant ces cinq semaines qui
viennent
face à des mots de désespérance ce sont
les défis d'avenir que nous voulons pour
nos régions
ce que nous voulons pour l'avenir de
notre pays et la victoire de 2017
au sein de notre grande formation et
avec nos amis du centre et surtout aux
côtés de nicolas sarkozy